every project that i embark on
i put my heart and soul to do it and i
have a
very close relationship with the client
i listen
to their needs and understand what they
require from me
it is a space that i design not for me
but for the client
because it has to show the personality
of client it has to be a space
where they get happiness when they live
into the space and that is important to
me
i think my work no doubt i have projects
which are overseas projects but
it's very important to have a design
where it has to show that this design
actually has a singapore design identity
i have influence from the early
architects like le corbusier
mies van der rohe and oscar neva as well
as furniture designers
like charlotte parent search mole and
joe ponte
so this is obviously the early influence
that i have
in terms of how i understand design
it is important to understand especially
if you're doing interior design that
it has to relate to the external which
means we need to
respect the architecture we need to
understand the architecture
we need to understand back standard
spaces like the landscape
we need to understand how this element
has to be combined as a whole
my design style is modern classic and
luxe
modern in a sense that the design will
last over time
and what is what we call timeless design
classic which has a similar meaning is
that this design
will be carry over not just a decade but
in 20 in 30 years time and lux is about
using the material
inside the space so that the quality of
the space will be improved
through the selection of material
my advice to young designers is to be
passionate in whatever you do
to work hard and to strive for design
excellence
it's important to create a design that
is able to represent
singapore and this design will be
uniquely
singapore i'm peter tay interior
designer
designer
you